[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
March 1st I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
we often hear about layoffs as a way for
companies to reduce staff and save money
but many companies are finding other
ways to thin their ranks and not
classify them as layoffs Wall Street
Journal workplace and management
reporter chip cutter looked into that
and he joins me now hey chip thanks very
much for being with us always a pleasure
thanks for having me so Chip the idea of
finding ways to let workers go without
actually laying them off that isn't new
right it's not companies have long had
ways of pushing employees out without
firing them they could reorganize teams
or require employees to report to a new
boss or make them take on a new project
all of those changes could prompt
staffers to look elsewhere for work okay
so what's going on now that's different
well right now we're seeing a wave of
high profile layoffs particularly among
white collar workers but a number of
companies are taking other approaches to
manage their workforces and so some are
adding new restrictions on remote work
others are stepping up scrutiny and
performance reviews and some companies
are requiring staff offers to relocate
across the country to keep their jobs if
they're going to close certain offices
now you mentioned performance reviews
how do they play into this well for GE
reviews can really determine whether
someone wants to stay at a company or
not and I think an interesting example
here is that the Facebook and Instagram
parent meta the company has issued
thousands of subpar performance reviews
in recent weeks and some people inside
the company have told us that they see
this as a sign that those workers may
want to go elsewhere then and so a tough
performance review or putting someone on
a performance Improvement plan whatever
that might be all of that can be sort of
a signal to workers about their value
within an organization and I think some
employees may say rather than put up
with this or after a tough review I'm
just going to go elsewhere and look for
another job so what rights do employees
have in a situation like that well
employees don't have a lot of Rights in
most American workplaces this is at will
employment and a company is free to
change the terms or review workers
however they would like what power
workers have is to look for jobs
elsewhere this is still a tough labor
market it's a 3.4 percent unemployment
rate it's still very tight historically
so workers could look for jobs elsewhere
of course some don't want to do that and
I think the kind of layoffs that we've
seen in a number of high profile
companies have spooked some employees
we've heard from a number of employers
that attrition is down for example
because people just may not feel like
this is the time to look for other work
so there is a shift in the balance of
power that's happening across the
corporate sphere now how much does this
have to do with the sharp hiring
increases that we saw during the
pandemic well companies really ramped up
hiring in the pandemic we saw a number
of companies say repeatedly they just
couldn't find enough people they were
desperate to get new people in the door
so many companies now feel reluctant to
admit that they hired too quickly in the
pandemic or incorrectly forecast growth
and so some of them are now looking to
correct and that could be behind some of
these moves that some have said are sort
of thinly disguised layoffs one
Economist told me it's very much a
layoff without calling in the layoff
yeah so is there a stigma associated
with layoffs why would companies try to
avoid that term when it comes to
Staffing changes well a layoff can hurt
a company's reputation it could jar
employees it could hurt a company's
culture there are many reasons why a
company wouldn't want to go to that
drastic step of a big Workforce
reduction and so I think some of these
other tactics though can be a way to
thin out the workforce without going to
the step of a layoff and one former HR
person told me that not singling people
out in the layoff can also prevent a
company from being sued if people you
know would be unhappy in a layoff but if
they sort of choose to go on their own
they may not sort of feel the desire to
really sort of holding the company
accountable that could all just sort of
change the factors here oh so the
workers feel less wronged that's right
employees may feel less wronged if they
sort of willingly choose to go somewhere
else versus being subject to a layoff
that forces them out the door you know
during the pandemic we talked a lot
about how the balance of power had
shifted from managers to workers what
does that balance look like now the
balance is changing once again
particularly at White Collar companies
CEOs and other Executives do feel like
the labor market is shifting a bit and
that they're able to impose some of
their own preferences on the workforce
so we see that in some of the return to
office announcements for example
companies like Disney and Amazon have
recently put out edicts saying that
workers will be required in the office a
certain number of days a week and so
these are all signs that companies now
feel a little more emboldened to push
for changes that they may have wanted
earlier in the pandemic but felt they
couldn't do because they were so nervous
about losing people if bosses feel like
the labor market is softening a bit now
they may not just be as concerned that
any of these moves might cause people to
quit so where have these staff
reductions been happening it seems like
the reductions that get the most
attention are the ones happening in the
tech sector most of the reductions have
come from the tech sector we've seen
just so many tech companies which
expanded so much in the pandemic start
to sort of pull back a little bit slow
hiring and have these layoffs but we are
seeing layoffs trickle into other parts
of the economy too we've seen
manufacturing companies we've seen big
consumer names retailers and others
announced layoffs so it's not just
limited to Tech at this point but Tech
certainly has gotten the most attention
all right that's Wall Street Journal
reporter chip cutter chip thank you very
much for being with us you're welcome
thanks for having me and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you